men are the problem men
men leave are men trash men or men
it's because men are afraid of being called the problem
but women are afraid men are gonna kill them
if you're genuinely afraid of being called the problem
you need to grow up and go into my comment section
cause if you think that that's bad
you should see what men say to me on a daily basis
when I talk about the fact that women are being killed by their partners
men in my comments say I hope you're next
men in the comments tell me the most vile and disgusting hateful
threatening violent things on a daily basis
but you guys are scared of being told that you're the problem
honestly like I'm embarrassed for you
women have a higher pain tolerance than men
and that is not just physical
we have a higher emotional pain tolerance
you guys can't handle anything complaining because women have a platform now
women have a voice and they're finally speaking their truth
and you can't handle it cause you were born into a world that says
you're never gonna hear the truth of who you are and what you are
you're just gonna be able to take take
take and things have changed
times have changed
and you can keep taking but you will be held accountable
well in his response
which you should watch to the video
brings up the famous Margaret Atwood quote
which is men are afraid women will laugh at them
women are afraid men will kill them
trust me I get it
it's tough hearing that you're the problem all the time
and you know what it's uncomfortable
it is I know that
because I've also felt uncomfortable at being held accountable
for the privileges that I possess
and I've learnt how to sit in that discomfort
and truly reflect on the ways that I'm privileged
and the ways I can be better
but I also know it's possible to do that
and I don't see a lot of you trying
listen to me when women voice our fears about men
it is not with the purpose of making men into the enemy
it is with the purpose of sharing our reality
maybe instead of scrolling scrolling
scrolling past in annoyance being that victim
maybe step into your manhood
think about are you actually a man
are you actually an initiated man who can sit with what that means
instead of feeling attacked and victimized
maybe it's time to listen
learn and reflect
reflect on the truth of the matter
reflect on why people are saying this about men
if you're taking it personally
why you take it personally
it's not about you really
it's not about you on a personal level
is it or is it cause
why are you taking personally cause
here's the tea changing men's behaviour
which is what needs to happen
whether or not you see yourself as the man who needs to change
or not changing men's behaviour
it doesn't require defensiveness from you
it requires empathy and understanding
world where women feel safer is gonna be a world where men feel safer too